[Applause]  lamello  first points to the ball game for  lamilla ball mclemore  still hot  two-point ball game i'm sorry five-point  ball game  second three-pointer for lamelo this guy  was considered a disappointment  lottery pick yeah in sacramento for a  whole bunch of years  finally found a good roll la la ball  third  three-pointer  hornets lead by a singleton transition  three  level oh he's feeling it here in the  first half  in the lineup they have a lot of guys  same size that could switch and try to  keep guys in front of them  64-60 as we send it back to charlie  check that  67  that would have tied the ball game up  harness with numbers if they hurry  lamelo straight on look got it  oh the kids got game  pj washington over to lamello  got it that's now  seven triples for lavello